is China's economy finally moving along
again industrial production rose last
month by 6.2 percent over a year ago
normally that's nothing to get excited
about
but given the economy's recent weak
performance it was something for Beijing
to celebrate as proof that it's not
suffering from its trade war with the US
you know I should polish the Chinese
economy remains stable and shows
progress illustrates that even in a
complex and difficult international
environment China's economy still has
strong potential and plenty of room for
action markets and shanghai reacted
positively to the news closing a half a
percent higher at their highest mark in
six weeks there's a renewed belief that
China's trade war with America has been
put on ice both countries have just
agreed to sit out the next round of
tariff increases the u.s. cancelled a
further 160 billion dollars in customs
duties in the so-called first phase of
the agreement also tariffs that have
already been put into effect will be
reduced China in turn announced it would
import 200 billion dollars worth of u.s.
goods including agricultural products
and intellectual property will be better
protected as well
negotiations are set to begin again in
January but observers say it's too early
to predict that an end to the trade war
is in sight because most of the tariffs
remain in force they could still be a
few weeks before forecasts are possible
Abba Morra I'm joined by Halawa Phan
Daniels from the German Institute for
International and security affairs where
she heads the research division the
America is good to have you with us so
first of all no further tariffs
certainly this weekend what's prompted
this move well there's an electric
campaign in the US that's just starting
this also the impeachment process so the
president's under pressure the US
president to come up with results and
it's been actually a pretty lucky week
for him because there was a preliminary
deal with Democrats on the u.s. MCA
agreement with Canada and Mexico and now
a phase 1d
with China which has yet to be signed of
course yeah it's not written in stone
just yet not yet and it's also not a big
idea I mean it's a pretty narrow
achievement it's basically an agreement
on agricultural exports of 40 billion
that will go from the u.s. to China now
but not much has been reached on
intellectual property rights and all the
other difficult problems that are
surround between China and the US so
what more needs to happen for those
problems to be resolved and to reduce or
even remove the existing tariffs the US
has said clearly that they will continue
to evaluate the progress of this trade
year being implemented and then decide
if there will be a further agreement
phase 2 dia that would then include
further reforms on the Chinese side
economic major structure economic
reforms but it's not clear that the
Chinese will actually bend to those US
requests that's not obvious at all at
this point so there's still a lot of
work to be done and this of course
happens as the World Trade Organization
happens to face its worst crisis ever
and that largely because of the United
States sort of blocking it what's the
u.s. after well the major conflict is
about conflict resolution within the WTO
and it seems that the US government is
aiming for a situation that looks much
more like before the founding of the WTO
in 1995 so what they are after is
basically being able to place a veto
against any kind of rulings that come
out of the dispute settlement what does
that mean then for global trade as we
know it well would mean that any kind of
results that come out of these dispute
settlement bodies are no longer binding
but any country can just place a veto
and say no we won't implement and then
you know that's the end of the story
so it'll be a regress is there any sign
or do you have any hopes at the WTO
eventually can sort of recover from all
this I think so I think the European
Union together with other countries can
actually they they came up with
solutions already within the WTO an
alternative dispute settlement
that could be implemented between a
large number of countries including
China India and other big players so
there are options the but it's of course
it's difficult with the one of the
biggest economies just being blocking
everything any kind of reform at this
point right Lara Danielle's phone
Danielle's there from the German
Institute for International and security
affairs thank you so much for your time
thank you